Film Courage: What are some common mistakes
you see web series creators make over and
over again?
Kathie Fong Yoneda: I think one of the things
that a lot of people don’t understand exactly
what a web series is sometimes what they are
trying to do is they’re trying to take maybe
a script (a film script) maybe like 100 minutes
or 90 minutes and they’re trying to do is
they’re trying to cut it up into episodes.
It would be like this is my movie and I’m
trying to cut it up.
So the problem is when this is shown web series
audiences are very fickle people and the main
this is because we’ve got that little mouse
and we click on that thing anytime or television
set (we just click the remote) and change
channels.
And you can click and go onto a another web
series very easily if you don’t catch someone’s
attention right away.
People don’t understand you can’t just
take a film script and chop it up and that’s
it.
You have 90 minutes or 100 minutes to tell
the whole story.
You need to capture somebodies attention right
away within the first 2 or 3 minutes.
Especially because I’m with the LA WebFest
(I’m on their board) and one of our common
complaints when we get people sending things
in is they will have web series that will
15, 20, 25 minutes long.
That’s not a web series, that’s a short
film.
In fact a lot of the web fest people now we’re
trying to limit it because a web series is…because
we like to show them and we like to show as
many episodes as we can but we can’t if
someone’s got 25-minute episodes then it’s
taking up too much time.
So we tell people a web series (if it’s
a comedy) it should be longer than 6 minutes.
If it’s a drama, no more than 8-10 minutes
at the most per episode.
So I think it’s understanding that web series
should be looked at as its own medium.
Not just this is a movie and just cut it up
into little pieces.
Film Courage: Interesting.
And how many episodes would you recommend
most web series have?
Kathie: You know the average web series, I’ve
seen some that were as little as 4-5 episodes
for one season.
I would say the average is 8 to 10 a season.
And dramas tend to be slightly longer, as
I mentioned most of them are between 8-10
minutes and the comedies are more like 4 to
6 minutes.
Some of them are as short as a minute and
a half to 2 minutes.
Film Courage: What are your thoughts about
a web series creator making a web series and
aiming for sponsorship right away.
I’m hearing this from a lot of web series
people “We’re looking for sponsorship.”
And that’s like the only goal behind it.”
Kathie: Well if you don’t have a product,
you’re not going to get a sponsor.
I mean it’s like the same thing as saying
“Okay, I’ve got to find a studio to distribute
my movie.”
Well, okay but you haven’t written the movie
yet.
So I think a lot of people get mislead into
thinking well if I can get this crowdfunding
campaign going and money raised, then I can
do all of this.
Most of the web series people that I’ve
talked to, they just started out because they
thought they needed to do it and they wanted
to do it.
And they had so much fun.
It was just a bunch of people, a lot of times
they were cousins or brothers or siblings
or something.
A lot of times it was just kids in a dorm
that just decided “Let’s do one.”
They just did it.
And we’ve had some that have been so primitive
as just using their iPhone.
And we’ve had some that have been very sophisticated
where it was actually wonderful technical
things with cameras and stuff like that.
And some have one brilliant special effects
and things like that.
It just depends on where you’re at and what
your story is.
Some of the more successful stories though
are the ones where people just thought they
needed to be done and they had an interesting
set of characters in an unusual circumstance.
As an example…I love the stories that come
behind the web series and one of the things
that I’ve been doing is that I’ve been
asked to go to the different web fests around
the world talking about web series that concern
social issues.
And it’s very interesting because one of
them is called Fasciteene because it involves
a situation that is in Lebanon (Beirut, Lebanon).
The creator of it, her name is Katia and she
grew up in Lebanon…a middle class family
or upper middle class (I don’t know) but
they own some apartments.
And she did her college work in London because
there weren’t any Universities that she
felt she could go to in Lebanon that would
support the fact that she wanted to do communication
and television and stuff like that.
And anyway her family sent her up there.
She actually did quite well.
She started working for the BBC and she was
their Aljazeera contact because she could
speak in several different languages and she
even got some awards but her parents were
getting older so she made the decision to
move back to Beirut and stay with her family
for awhile and see how things were there.
And she realized that when she met with some
of her friends there that a lot of things
had gotten worse in Lebanon.
They had had some bombings and there were
areas (neighborhoods) where it used to be
safe and it was no longer safe.
She realized that there was something that
she wanted to say and she felt that women
(especially) were the ones who were not progressing.
Fascateen is about three women who eventually
become best friends.
And one is where her husband has left her
and their kid at his parent’s place.
He is through with marriage.
He doesn’t want to be married.
He doesn’t want to be a father.
And she is left by herself with their young
child with the in-laws.
And she doesn’t know what she should do.
She does not get along with the in-laws.
They blame her for everything wrong.
“Our son wouldn’t have left if you were
a good wife or a good mother.”
They constantly blame her.
So she needs to find a place to stay.
She ends up finding a place to stay in an
apartment building and the daughter of the
apartment owner and she is very creative and
she likes to make movies and she’s just
curious about things and she writes and she
does poetry and she’s just very creative.
And the father keeps saying “When are you
going to settle down and get married?
I ought to just marry you off!”
And she doesn’t want that to happen.
And the father though is…her parents are
very well-meaning but they’re very old fashioned
about it.
But she sweet talks her father into accepting
this woman into being in one of their apartments.
The woman has to work so she takes the son
and she’s a
tutor so she tutors for this woman who is
very wealthy and she has a couple of kids
and her husband works in Dubai and so she’s
by herself and so she’s got a Nanny and
she’s got all of this but she needs a tutor
so the woman who is divorced is the tutor.
But it’s this three women who actually become
very good friends.
And what she did at the end of each web series
was they got to vote on the ending.
Film Courage: The audience did?
Kathie: They got to vote on the ending and
then they would show the ending at the beginning
of the next episode (whichever one got to
vote) and I asked her “Well why did you
do that?”
And she said “I wanted to give women the
opportunity to vote, to have an option.
Because they have so few options in my country.”
And so Fasateen won the grand prize at the
Marseille web fest.
Film Courage: Wow.
Good for her.
And I’m sorry, what was the name of the
web series?
Kathie: Fasateen and it’s an amazing one.